I feel like Tom cried at Taxi Driver
or something once, something really-
"He just wanted to drive his taxi."
"I think that mohawk looks really good."
Man, the version of me that
lives in your heads is-
"I am talking to you. I am talking to
you. I'm trying to be your friend."
"You're not alone."
"I just want to communicate."
"We're trying to have a dialogue."
"You did a really good job
making a slidey gun." Yeah.
So today we're going to talk about the most
tear jerking moments from animated movies. Now,
obviously not all animated movies
will make you cry. Some that do,
or the ones that you remember fondly, are the ones
that you never want to watch again. But anyway,
we've got a list here on Looper dot com
full of movies that might make you cry.
Nina, what are some tear jerking moments from
animated movies that reliably can make you cry?
Ooh, well, I have two fun stories about some
entries on this list because I think the biggest,
not offender, but the biggest tear
factory in animated movies is Pixar.
Every Pixar movie has a moment
that just makes you question
your place on earth, and humanity, and if there's
a God and stuff. So I once cried so loudly
and intensely over the opening of Up on a megabus
that I was taking from Philadelphia to Pittsburgh,
that someone got up and moved to a
different seat. They were like, "No,
I don't want to do this.
This girl's nuts." Yeah. I'd-
You can imagine what that person's
thinking the moment you start weeping.
They're just like, "I've got to sit next to
the crying girl all the way to Pittsburgh?"
No, no, no. Brian, they weren't
sitting next to me, they were sitting
behind me and they still moved further away.
Oh, no. That's so much worse.
It's so much worse. And it's a seven
hour megabus ride from Philadelphia
to Pittsburgh, it's a really long ride.
And you watched Up several times.
No, I watched it once. I remember I had downloaded
a bunch of movies to watch on the ride, and I knew
up was sad but I guess I didn't believe people and
I was like, "It won't be that sad." And then I'm
blubbering like a newborn baby while people
are like, "Uh-oh, disturbed girl on the bus."
They've got their phones out and
they have nine and one pushed,
and then they're going to hit
the last one when you freak out.
"Should we..?" Yeah. So that was Up and I didn't-
"Do we all call or does one call
do it for crazy person on the bus?"
Yeah, it's a bystander effect thing,
"Can we confirm someone's doing it? Do
we tell the driver? We still have six hours left-"
"We don't want to overload the circuits."
"... In this ride." So that was-
"She's just been watching Ellie's death
on repeat for the last 300 miles and-"
Okay, that I did not do.
"I feel like maybe she's ramping
up to something. We've got to..."
"I found what I think is a manifesto
or a shopping list, I'm not sure."
"She's Uptown Girl at the same time, and
I just think that's very suspicious."
So that was a bad one. The second one isn't
even as good, that's the better story,
I should have finished with that. But the
second one is Inside Out, which I had seen
five times already by the time I turned it on on
an airplane. And I know that there's a science
reason why people cry more on airplanes, it
has to do with air pressure or something,
there have actually been studies about this,
which I can tell you is true because a good
friend of mine once cried over Jumanji: Welcome to
the Jungle on an airplane and that's his excuse.
Oh, no.
That's good to know because I have a story next.
Yeah. So I turned on Inside Out, I was like, "I've
seen this movie before." I'm a nervous flyer so I
like to watch stuff I've seen because it's
comforting to me, and Amy Poehler started to
speak and I burst into tears and was like,
"Nevermind, next movie." I don't know why,
I'd already seen it. Anyway, my pick is Boo from
Monsters, Inc. The end of that movie makes me
bawl, it's so sad. Boo is so cute, the
relationship with Sully is so good. Monsters,
Inc. is I would say probably my second favorite
Pixar movie and I think Inside Out is first,
but Monsters, Inc. has a very special
place in my heart. It's funny,
it's heartwarming, and when he has to say
goodbye to her and she doesn't fully comprehend
that that's what's happening and is trying
to play with him? That is just so crushing.
Oh, that's really sad. When she opens
up the closet door and he's not there.
Yeah, no. Oh, I'm getting emotional thinking
about it. So I should stop talking about it, but
I love... Let's end the video.
Quick-
No, Monsters, Inc.-
What grade were you in when you saw
that movie? What grade were you in?
Twelfth.
What year did Monsters, Inc. come out? Twelfth.
No, what year did Monsters, Inc. come out?
What was it, '97?
No, it was after that.
I think I was probably...
Monsters, Inc. came out in 2001. So it came
out when I was 10 or 11, depending on time
of year. So I probably saw it shortly after...
I was probably 11, and I'm sure I just wept.
I was in college.
Well, Brian, I thought you were
teaching at university because
you'd already graduated years and years and years-
Yeah, I was in college, I had tenure.
Yeah, because you're old. Anyway-
Because I'm so old. Okay, I'd
like to jump off what you said-
You were just taking an anthropology
class from Dr. Henry Jones Jr.
That's right. Inside Out, though. That
movie didn't do much for me, and here's why.
You have mentioned that, yeah.
The reason is because I spent so long
getting wrapped up in my own head,
trying to figure out how the
inside of this kid's head worked.
Like the mythology of this universe?
Yeah. I was like, are these little guys
who aren't the emotions, do they live,
do they have apartments? Do they go to sleep when
she goes to sleep? But what about the people..?
I couldn't figure out the municipality situation.
You wondered if they have apartments?
Okay, I don't disagree with you on this.
Actually I had the same thing, I was like,
"So wait, does she have any agency in
her own life? Or are we all just..?"
I couldn't stop thinking about
the structures of her mind-
You guys suck.
And how the people living in her brain function,
and how they live. I was like, "Hang on a second,
I can't..." Because for me, if it was just the
emotions in the main part of the brain that
you saw, the stars of the show, I'd be like, "All
right, fine, got it. Herman's Head, but for kids,
got it. I'm down. No problem." But then
you start introducing these pipes and
the movie studio for the dream situation and
Bing Bong shows up, and I'm like, "Whoa."
I like to think that this is your thought
process on any movie, where you're like,
"You know, it's all well and good, but
then there's pipes? I don't know anymore."
"How could a basilisk even get into
the pipe in the first place?"
I just couldn't figure it out.
"And Hogwarts can't be real
because magic doesn't exist."
No, I'm just saying that particular movie took
me out of it just because I couldn't quite
wrap my head around it all.
That's really interesting too, because there was
a huge push with that movie where neurologists
worked with the writers to figure out a way to
depict how the memory... The memory system is like
we have core memories and then we have subsidiary
ones, like the ones that we're throwing out-
Do you ever think about thinking? Do you ever
think about thinking and get freaked out about
how you're looking at something, even though
you're looking at the window and that's not-
Well, now I will, and I have plenty of
anxiety already, so thanks a lot, Brian.
You're very welcome. Anyway, my pick is-
I don't really think about most things.
... Toy Story 3.
Okay.
Ah.
So here in Toy Story 3-
Oh, the one where the toys accept their death.
That was the one, that was the moment. So here
on the Looper dot com article we have is where
Andy gives the toys to Bonnie.
That is really sad.
That's a very good moment for this,
but for me it was when they're all in the
incinerator holding hands, and my wife-
They've all come to terms with it.
Yeah, and I'm like, "Aah." I was crying
like a maniac because I was just like,
"What is happening? These toys are
about to die." I one million percent
thought that the toys were about to die.
Pixar does this a lot, they play very fast and
loose with... Like in Wally, when he gets reset,
you're like, "He's gone forever." You're
convinced. They're very good at being like, "No,
we've taken this character away
from you." And it is cruel.
And it's never happened.
It's never happened, I don't know why I
keep falling for it. Probably because of Up.
It's because we're all adults
with trust issues. Yeah.
Yeah.
This is exactly why I don't... and I
know I'm not about to make any friends,
I don't like Pixar, guys.
Oh, no.
Shut the video off.
And it's because of that-
... I have the floor.
You don't like how manipulative they are.
That's exactly it. I think that
Inside Out had the most indicative
example of this and it's the scene where
they're like, "We're going to make Richard
Kind into a cartoon elephant and then
have him say, 'Goodbye, everybody.'"
There was no reason to do that besides that
they couldn't afford to send a guy to every
theater and stomp on the audience's feet
one at a time. And that's what Pixar movies-
That's not true, they can afford to do that.
It happens every single-
They could afford to do that,
that's true. And they animate
one fewer good dinosaur in the-
If anyone could be your sad, disappearing,
imaginary friend, it's Richard Kind.
Yeah, no, perfect casting.
They didn't even have to make him an elephant,
they could have just animated Richard Kind-
It could've just been him, yeah.
He's the best.
Uh, no. Yeah, no, he's... I had the same thing.
The first time that I noticed it was with Up,
and it was the first time that I got
physically angry at a Pixar movie.
Were you on a megabus?
Were you on a megabus.
I was on an Amtrak. They disconnected my
car and they abandoned me in the middle of
the Appalachian mountains... The year that Up
came out, I think it was 2008, is that right?
Nine, I think.
2009, it was this really rough year for my family.
My dad was going through a bunch of stuff
and we're like, "You know what we should do,
us kids? We should take my dad to see a fun
movie. Let's go see a fun cartoon together."
Oh, no.
Then the first five minutes of that movie were,
"Hey, don't forget that everybody dies alone.
Let's all just sit in silence and contemplate
the fact that everybody dies alone."
And they do that in every single one of
those movies, and it drives me up the wall.
I understand that we're trying to make an
emotionally connective story, but my God, man-
I'm sorry.
Dick move.
I'm just imagining. Again, it's happened
to you and your family and that bums me
out because I know you guys. But in the
abstract, the idea that you as a family
are going through a rough time and you're like,
"I know what we need, let's see a fun cartoon-"
A Pixar movie.
Right? Yeah, no, I-
I have a similar story. After my
grandpa died, I took my cousin to
the movie to distract ourselves from
it, and we saw The Master of Disguise-
Yeah. That didn't fix it?
That's the whole story. It took my mind
off my dead grandpa for 90 minutes,
and I was like, "What is this?"
When my dad was having his hip replaced,
my friend took me to see A Star is Born,
which is not a happy ending of a film.
Oh, whoops. Nope.
And I remember being like,
"Well, I'm distracted at least
by being very sad about this movie instead."
They should have called it A Star Will Die.
It's an ironic name considering how the movie
goes. Anyway, other picks for this list... So Tom,
you didn't have any picks for this list. Iron
Giant, though. Iron Giant is high on my list.
It's a great choice.
Did that one make you cry?
I've never cried, you guys.
I'm going to spoil Iron Giant, I've already
spoiled it in one of our previous videos,
I'm going to spoil it now again,
so just click away or mute me.
Okay, so he's-
The robot explodes.
... Flying up through space
towards the nuke, and he goes Superman
because he learned that Superman's a hero-
Because he just saw Eternals.
... And he closes his eyes and then he blows
up, sacrificing himself to save the earth.
It's so sad.
It kills me every time. Okay, spoilers
are over. That never made you cry?
Nah, no, I didn't really feel anything.
No, when Tom was born he didn't cry,
he just made eye contact with his
mother and was like, "What's up?"
I did, I stared her down, "I
know what you're going to do."
You were like, "Big mistake."
"Shouldn't have done that, Mom."
"Now it's my turn."
What?
Another really good one on this
list... Tom, did you see Coco?
I never saw Coco.
That is a Pixar movie so...
Coco is a good one, where he connects
with his grandma and plays the song
that her father had played for her. And again,
my wife and I saw that in the theaters and
we just were weeping. But that was a weirdly
emotional day for us for some reason, because
that was the movie that opened with the Olaf's
insane Christmas short, the 20 minute short?
The one that had to be removed, yeah.
That's why it was emotional?
That made us cry too and I don't know why.
Oh, okay. I thought you were saying
that you were just particularly
vulnerable that day because you
got to watch so much extra Olaf.
I don't know what it was, but Olaf going around
trying to find what makes everybody happy on
the holidays smashed my soul. It was just like,
"You're going to cry now because holidays
are magic." And I was just like, "Yeah, they
are magic." "Everybody has a special holiday."
It's like taking whatever drug they give you when
you get your wisdom teeth taken
out, you're just like, "Aah."
Brian, have you ever cried over
Nutcracker and the Four Realms?
I need to see that movie, I need to watch it.
Maybe it'll make you cry.
I hope so.
I'd like-
I feel like Tom cried at Taxi Driver
or something once, something really-
"He just wanted to drive his taxi."
"I think that mohawk looks really good."
Man, the version of me that
lives in your heads is-
"I am talking to you. I am talking to
you. I'm trying to be your friend."
"You're not alone."
"I just want to communicate."
"We're trying to have a dialogue."
"You did a really good job
making a slidey gun." Yeah.
The only other one I want to
add that isn't on this list,
but for me... You mentioned that apparently
you're more susceptible to crying on planes,
which is really good to know because I saw
Moana on a plane and that got me immediately.
It did?
So did I, yeah.
Oh my God. And I have PTSD from it because
we play the soundtrack for our kid sometimes,
and even that fun opening song when they
sing that line, "And no one leaves," and
I'm just like, "Oh, no one leaves. Because
they used to be wayfarers, they used to-"
I cried at the end of that movie, and I
was flying with my friend who's like...
if a Shiba Inu was a person, she doesn't cry
a lot. And I was like, "Oh no, I don't want
her to see me cry. I've never cried in front
of her, this is so weird." But I looked over
and she was crying too, and I was like, "Yes,
thank God. Okay, we're both losers, it's fine."
Yeah. I told my wife on the flight, I watched
that on the flight and she fell asleep and I
was just like, "You should watch Moana. It made
me cry a lot." And she watched and she was like,
"That was fine." No reaction to it. She
was like, "Yeah, I guess it was okay."
The only other instance I can think of
where that kind of thing happened on a
plane was I saw Game Night on a plane. I
didn't cry, I just laughed like an idiot.
You didn't cry during Game Night?
No, I didn't cry during Game Night, but
I was worried that people were going to
want to change seats because
I was laughing like a maniac.
Try crying next time, they will move.
I'd get my own seat, finally.
That should get a lot of
people shot by an air marshal.
Thanks for watching, please hit like
and subscribe. And if you watch this far
please hit something and leave a
comment to tell us that you did,
because I don't believe that
anyone's looking at me right now-